[Applause]
picture a world with a variety of
landforms
it has a dense atmosphere within which
winds sweep across its surface and rain
falls
it has mountains and plains rivers lakes
and seas
sand dunes and some impact craters
sounds like earth right this is titan
in august 1981 voyager 2 captured this
image of saturn's largest moon
the voyager missions have traveled
farther than ever before
making the solar system and beyond part
of our geography
but this image this hazy moon was a
stark reminder of just how much mystery
remained
we learned an exponential amount as the
voyagers flew by it and yet
we had no idea what lay beneath this
atmospheric blanket
was there an icy surface with landforms
like those of the other moons that had
been observed at saturn and jupiter
or perhaps simply a vast global ocean of
liquid methane
shrouded by the obscuring haze titan's
surface was a huge outstanding mystery
that cassini huygens an orbiter lander
pair launched in 1997
was designed to solve after arrival in
the early images cassini sent back of
titan's surface
only heightened the allure it took
months for us to understand what we were
seeing on the surface
to determine for example that the dark
stripes which were initially so
unrecognizable
that we referred to them as cat
scratches were actually dunes made of
organic sand
over the course of the 13 years cassini
spent studying saturn and its rings and
moons
we had the privilege of going from
knowing almost nothing about the surface
of titan
to understanding its geology the role
the atmosphere plays in shaping its
surface
and even hints of what lies deep beneath
that surface
indeed titan is one of several ocean
worlds
moons in the cold outer solar system
beyond the orbits of mars and the
asteroid belt
with immense liquid water oceans beneath
their surfaces
titan's interior ocean may have more
than 10 times as much liquid water
as all of the earth's rivers lakes seas
and oceans combined
and at titan there are also exotic lakes
and seas of liquid methane and ethane
on the surface ocean worlds are some of
the most
fascinating places in the solar system
and we have only just begun to explore
them
this is dragonfly at the johns hopkins
applied physics laboratory
we are building this mission for nasa's
new frontiers program
scheduled to launch in 2026 and reach
titan in 2034
dragonfly is a rotorcraft lander similar
in size to the mars rovers are about the
size of a small car
titan's dense atmosphere combined with
its low gravity
make it a great place to fly and that's
exactly what dragonfly is designed to do
technically an octocopter dragonfly is a
mobile laboratory
that can fly from place to place taking
all of its scientific instruments with
it
dragonfly will investigate titan in a
truly unique way studying details of its
weather and geology
and even picking up samples from the
surface to learn what they're made of
all told dragonfly will spend about
three years exploring titan
measuring its detailed chemistry
observing the atmosphere and how it
interacts with the surface
and even listening for earthquakes or
technically titan quakes
in titan's crust the dragonfly team
hundreds of people across north america
and around the world
is hard at work on the design for this
mission developing the rotorcraft
its autonomous navigation system and its
instrumentation
all of which will need to work together
to make science measurements on the
surface of titan
dragonfly is the next step in our
exploration of this fascinating natural
laboratory
in flying by voyager hinted at the
possibilities
in orbiting saturn for over a decade and
descending through titan's atmosphere
cassini and huygens pulled titan's veil
back a bit further
dragonfly will live in the titan
environment
where so far our only close-up view is
this image the huygens probe took
in january 2005.
in many ways titan is the closest known
analog we have to the early earth
the earth before life developed here
from cassini-huygens measurements we
know that the ingredients for life
at least life as we know it have existed
on titan
and dragonfly will be fully immersed
within this alien environment
looking for compounds similar to those
that might have supported the
development of life
here on earth and teaching us about the
habitability
of other worlds habitability is a
fascinating concept
what's necessary to make an environment
suitable to host life
whether life as we know it here on earth
or perhaps exotic life that is developed
under very different conditions
the possibility of life elsewhere has
inspired human imagination
and exploration throughout history on a
grand scale it's why the ocean worlds
and the outer solar system have become
such important targets for study
it's the what if that drives human
exploration
we don't know how chemistry took the
step to biology here on earth
but similar chemical processes may have
happened on titan
where organic molecules have had the
opportunity to mix
with liquid water at the surface has
organic synthesis progressed under these
conditions
and if so how far we don't know
yet what we will learn from dragonfly
this fundamentally human endeavor is
tantalizing
it's a search for building blocks
foundations
chemical steps like those that
ultimately led to life on earth
we're not sure exactly what we will find
when we get to titan
but that's exactly why we're going
in 1994 carl sagan wrote on titan
the molecules that have been raining
down like manna from heaven
for the last four billion years might
still be there
largely unaltered deep frozen awaiting
the chemists from earth
we are those chemists dragonfly is a
search for greater understanding
not just of titan and the mysteries of
our solar system
but of our own origins thank you
[Music]
you